algum tempo atrás eu conheci uma garota
uma viagem super cabeça futurista
empreendedora super ligada nos
movimentos de inovação startup e papo
vai papo vem quando ela soube que eu era
advogada e que eu presidi a parte do
tribunal de ética da ordem dos advogados
ela falou eu estou falando com a pessoa
certa
entre vários questionamentos que ela me
fez
um deles foi o seguinte esse um lobo por
meio da inteligência artificial
ressuscitasse um determinado artista
supondo que o robô estudar se muito bem
o determinado artista um gogh um rio em
branco tarsila do amaral ficasse
absolutamente treinando com as cores
pincéis texturas perfil psicológico
histórico desse artista e elaborasse uma
obra como se fosse ele
ou seja esse artista estivesse vivo esta
seria a obra que ele faria a família
teria direito aos direitos autorais
dessa obra
os museus os institutos de pesquisa
alguém teria direitos sobre isso muda
alguma coisa se as obras deste artista
já estejam ou não em domínio público ou
vocês acham que é pirataria plágio ou é
mera em inspiração criação nova e
artística do roubo
ela então me fez essa pergunta e eu já
venho
uau o robô que é capaz de fazer esse
tipo de coisa por meio da inteligência
artificial
ele é pessoa física e pessoa jurídica ou
ele é
coisa o parlamento europeu disse que ele
é pessoa eletrônica
então hoje eu vim falar um pouco sobre
isso e sobre como a tecnologia vem
desafiando as leis os dilemas jurídicos
que estão surgindo com o avanço da
inteligência artificial e das lane
machines que são as máquinas com
capacidade de aprendizado e as reflexões
éticas que acompanham esta nova e
inexorável realidade eu trouxe alguns
cases para ilustrar por meio de exemplos
do que que nós estamos falando
o primeiro case é que eu impressão 3d de
armas objetos mesmo caso vou falar sobre
as armas a mas isso não existe ainda
karina existe sim um jovem trava uma
batalha com o governo americano uma
batalha judicial e venceu
reconhecendo seu direito a imprimir a
sua arma 3d em casa com a única
observação que ele deveria instalar um
pino de metal nessa arma para que ela
fosse captada por detectores de metais
porque senão nem isso
agora vamos supor então que eu cumpri la
mia resina plástica minha impressora na
minha casa eu baixo manual de instrução
online e imprimir minha arma e aí eu
cometer algum crime
cid homicídio ameaço dano patrimonial
existe algum tipo de responsabilidade
compartilhada e se quem baixou esse
manual de instrução online foi um menor
de idade
existe alguma diferença para a empresa
detentora deste manual de software em
termos de responsabilidade civil
o próximo case é o do robô investidor é
o que o antigo daí o empresário de ron
kong muito rico essa história também é
real tamanho ou inventando ele tem um
contrato um bom investidor que chamava
keyhan quais eram as super habilidades
do roubo ele poderia ler em fração de
segundos todas as notícias
do mundo de todos os jornais blogs sites
etc
ele poderia verificar o valor da cotação
das bolsas de todos os mercados do mundo
inteiro online fração de segundos
ele poderia analisar os balanços das
empresas
o preço das commodities não há nada
melhor que isso ele está muito na frente
de um ser humano do melhor ser humano do
mercado financeiro muito bem essa pessoa
então contra a globo e roubo foi lá e
perdeu 20 milhões de dólares
e aí esse caso foi noticiado pela bumba
há três meses atrás é um caso real ele
estava procurando quem processar de quem
é a responsabilidade
ele decidiu processar o agente que
vendeu o software pra ele porque ele
entendeu que o agente super qualificou
as qualidades do robô
o robô não era tão bom assim não houve
sentença ainda e eu pergunto se o robô
tivesse ganho 20 milhões de dólares será
que nós poderemos falar em algum tipo de
concorrência desleal é risco do negócio
o próximo case que eu trouxe aqui pra
gente falar é o dos veículos autônomos
um clipe com case clássico todos vocês
já devem ter ouvido falar
então vamos supor que onde você esteja
lá no seu carro o outono sentado no
banco de trás vendo um vídeo do terex
mauá
então a pessoa tá lá assistindo seu
vídeo o carro está dirigindo em uma
estrada e se depara com o caminhão
desgovernado vindo naquela direção e ele
tem duas opções se manter na sua faixa
bater de frente matar o seu proprietário
ou desviar e atropelou um grupo de
pessoas cinco pessoas que estão no
acostamento o que essa máquina tem que
decidir qual é a decisão dela
será que se ela desviar a gente vai
poder falar em legítima defesa de
terceiro
agora se você o robô se o instrumento
estivesse programado para agir de uma
forma vamos supor mais ética fazendo o
contraponto entre salvar duas pessoas
vou salvar cinco pessoas eu vou salvar
então cinco pessoas
vou bater vocês compraram esse carro
vocês seriam proprietários desse carro e
aí na onda de hackeamento que nós
estamos vivendo hoje se esse carro fosse
hackeado e programado pra atropelar ou
se ele fosse programado para bater e
causar danos a terceiros será que nós
poderíamos falar em caso fortuito e
força maior ou caso fortuito ou força
maior no direito é excludente de
responsabilidade
ninguém responde e aí caso fortuito ou
seria responsabilidade da empresa que
programou esse software e que não tomou
todas as medidas de segurança a ponto de
um hacker invadiu difícil né
aqui também é muito interessante não sei
se todos vocês conhecem
quer dizer a maioria talvez não deva
conhecer essa garota halimi que ela ela
está no instagram ela tem 1,6 milhões de
seguidores então ela tomar coca-cola vai
pacote ela é linda k vao ela tá cheia de
amigo é musicista ela dita tendências
ela é o máximo digital influência só que
ela não existe
o que foi fantástico e seu avatar ea
inter agitasse vocês colocarem um
comentário lá pra ela vai te responder
e aí ela começar a ditar tendências que
não sejam muito saudáveis para as
garotas ou se ela tiver algum discurso
culture sexta racista de ódio de quem é
a responsabilidade
quem está por trás disso está aqui então
é o mais maravilhoso de todos assim de
tão bizarro mas este homem ele deve ter
assistido aquele filme ro se cansou da
vida real com as mulheres
ele decidiu então se casar com o
programa e fez um casamento
interdimensional com um personagem de
realidade virtual isso não m
tira esse casamento aconteceu no japão
em novembro de 2018
ele fez festa ele foi de terno branco na
festa ele levou a noiva que máximo levar
a noiva no casamento
ele levou as taças de champanhe e se
considera um cara casado e ele ficou
muito bravo porque a mãe dele se recusou
a ir no casamento
e aí eu pergunto vocês dariam presentes
de casamento
cuidado que a noiva pode não gostar e e
esses exemplos então que eu falei eles
já estão acontecendo eles não são nem um
pouco hipotéticos eles estão no mundo
real eles trazem grandes dilemas dilemas
jurídicos e dilemas éticos como direito
vai solucionar estas questões
se hoje já existe um vácuo na legislação
em relação ao crescimento da sociedade o
que dirá em relação à tecnologia
impossível acompanhar e aí no direito
nós temos um instituto que se chama hard
cases como o próprio nome já diz hard
cases significa casos difíceis
ou seja não é a partir de um pensamento
lógico dedutivo simples que você
consegue pegar uma norma jurídica e
aplicar naquele caso concreto você não
consegue fazer isso quando se trata de
rádio case a então karina como que eu
resolvo um hard cases você resolve um
hard cases através da aplicação de
princípios
você pega princípios orientadores
analogias usos e costumes aplicar estes
princípios no dilema e assim resolve da
melhor maneira
sou pesando valores
e aí o que me incomoda mesmo é o
seguinte se é uma coisa que incomoda
demais porque quem aplica os princípios
que é que aplica os princípios é um juiz
o juiz é um homem ou uma mulher
dotado de princípios princípios próprios
princípios morais e éticos
idosos culturais filosóficos e políticos
então esta pessoa é um ser humano um
homem uma mulher
eles vão aplicar e tentar resolver um
dilema jurídico aplicando princípios
segundo os seus próprios princípios e
como que nós ficamos em termos de
segurança jurídica no meio disso tudo
considerando ainda que o brasil não
adota o sistema de precedentes no brasil
a gente tem um princípio que chama
princípio do livre convencimento do juiz
o que permite que você tenha uma decisão
judicial
diferente da sua vizinha para o mesmo
caso concreto se isso já existe o que
dirá
nesse campo da tecnologia e da
inteligência artificial
e aí vem o outro ponto fascinante
angustiante mas maravilhoso e são os
dilemas éticos quem é o mentor e o
desenvolvedor da inteligência artificial
também é uma pessoa a que o roubo foi
exposto
quer dizer que aquele carro ou aquele o
que o eu robô investidor ele foi
programado na china
no vale do silício nos estados unidos na
rússia no oriente médio ou na américa do
sul será que a decisão do algoritmo é a
mesma
será que a tecnologia é realmente neutra
como dizem todos os cientistas
me parece que não e aí eu pergunto será
que existem valores de conduta que
possam ser reconhecidos por toda a
humanidade e independentemente de onde a
pessoa estiver independente de cultura
raça região porque juridicamente é muito
difícil alguns países vão admitir a caça
outros não alguns países vão admitir a
pena de morte outros não alguns vão
admitir a arma as armas
outros dão mas e aí a ética existem
valores que possam ser reconhecidos por
toda a humanidade
eu queria perguntar vocês acreditam
que exista ética universal
pensando nisso então a união européia
editou sete premissas e diretrizes para
a construção de uma inteligência
artificial ética que possa ser confiável
eu vou compartilhar com vocês então
essas premissas
a primeira delas é a supervisão humana
a inteligência artificial ela deve agir
em benefício do ser humano mas deve ser
por ele sempre supervisionada
a segunda diretriz é a segurança técnica
ou seja a inteligência artificial ela
deve ser segura e evitar terrenos
a terceira é a privacidade de dados né
dizem que quem dominar os dados vai
dominar o mundo isso é muito delicado
então deve obedecer à privacidade de
dados dos usuários
a próxima premissa é a da transparência
a inteligência artificial ela deve ser
capaz de se auto explicar numa linguagem
simples não pode ser uma caixa preta a
próxima diretoria da diversidade a
inteligência artificial ela deve ser o
mais diversa possível evitando
preconceitos diversas de raça cor sexo
religião todo tipo de diversidade
preservação do meio ambiente a
inteligência artificial deve ser
construída de forma beneficiar toda a
humanidade e ser amiga do meio ambiente
preservar a terra preservar as florestas
os oceanos os punk tons preservar a
natureza é uma premissa fundamental para
perpetuação humana
todos somos um e isso não pode ser
considerado um clichê e por fim
responsabilidade porque a inteligência
artificial ela deve ser responsável e
responsabilizável
eu isso não só na europa mas no mundo
inteiro porque a inteligência artificial
faz bem não conhece fronteiras
e aí por fim eu encaminho encaminhando
aqui para o final da minha palestra da
minha apresentação que teve muito mais
perguntas do que respostas muito mais
provocações
eu poderia dizer que nós estamos vivendo
a revolução tecnológica assim como nós
vivemos a revolução agrícola ea
revolução industrial
de maneira que a revolução tecnológica
que um dia faria parte da linha do tempo
dos livros de história se é que os
livros vão existir ainda no futuro
eu que sou uma operadora do direito e
vocês que são não operadores do direito
todos nós que somos alvo e produto da
inteligência artificial
nós passaremos por grandes desafios de
ordem legal de ordem moral e de ordem
ética
de maneira que no campo do direito
na falta de algo mais específico neste
vasto e amplíssimo campo da tecnologia
será que nós podemos pensar no futuro
sem leis
obrigada
[Aplausos]